okay okay okay list of cold opens
ranking them talking about the best just
think of something brilliant you can do
this you can do it's just it's not
already rolling Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
yes folks it is time for a Doctor Who
ranking a list and this one voted on by
the members of my patreon page because
yes at any support level even a dollar a
month you do get to vote on topics you
get you also get to see the docket a
month in advance and there's other perks
as well my author Diaries are going up
on the patreon page as I work towards
publishing my novel that turned into a
longer plug than I have intended it to
anyways the cold open what is the cold
open the cold open is whatever goes on
in an episode of prior to the credits
starting to roll it is what hooks you
into this specific episode traditionally
the cold open would be to basically say
hey here's what's going on before the
credits go so that you get them to sit
and wash through the whole thing they're
not necessarily as as necessary as they
once were you know back when people were
you know actually had to watch live TV
they couldn't get it on DVR watch it
later stream it binge it whatever but
it's still kind of a nice tradition to
have so cold opens are strictly things
of the modern era of Doctor Who closest
thing that classic whoever did too cold
opens was to do sometimes do little
recap EEB it's before the credits
started am not even sure they did that I
might be imagining and in my head
messing that around I'm pretty sure they
just always started with the credits so
this is this list is going to be
exclusively new who entries so that
means series 1 all the way up through
series 11 is up for consideration and
this list was difficult more difficult
in fact then I thought it was going to
be but I've narrowed it down I've got my
list now please keep in mind I'm only
judging the cold opens not how they
resolved after the credits not how the
episode overall was only the cold opened
so in some cases there are good cold Oh
two episodes that are not especially
good otherwise please keep that in mind
so let us start with number 10 the
doctor's wife a little bit of mystery
here which i think is always a good
thing for a cold open to have you want
to sort of set up oh don't you want to
know a little bit more about this and
this has that but I think for me the big
hook in the cold open is the doctor
getting that box I've got mail his
excitement is a big part of what sells
this all the times of the cold open will
be used to instill a sense of mystery
fear danger but to go with this dub with
the doctor sense of joy and excitement
in that moment that's a nice change of
pace for a cold open and I really like
it as a starter number nine utopia this
one I kind of wanted to put higher but
some of the stuff that's intercut with
it brings it back down a little bit
because it does have like the little
glimpses of the future kind which you
know that they're they're they're fine
but well gets it on the list in the
first place is the reintroduction of
Captain Jack Harkness into the story
because we haven't seen him since
the end the finale of series one and now
he's back running doctor clinging to the
side of the TARDIS through the time
vortex as it thunders to the end of time
trying to get away from him as he just
clinging on to the side of it calling
for the doctor ah it's great to have him
back it shows his desperation at finding
the doctor again which is great to put
in there for folks who hadn't been
keeping up with Torchwood to get a sense
that oh wow like things can't be great
with him if he's that desperate so it's
a great bringing him back it's a great
set up for that he's not in a good place
it just works
number eight Heaven Sent this one like I
said a lot of them tend to have a sense
of mystery this one absolutely has that
you get little glimpses little images
it's a voiceover and a lot of its
disconnected you're not sure where it's
going now that in and of itself does not
necessarily make it great called open
there's if that's actually kind of an
easy go to here's some stuff that we'll
explain later that will make sense later
and that actually usually doesn't do it
for me but knowing that we're coming off
the back of face the Raven so the doctor
is in an angry place and he steps out of
that teleport thing and he steps forward
speaking to he doesn't even know he
doesn't know who did this to him he
doesn't know how he got here but he says
I will find you and I will never ever
stop not only do you believe him in that
moment but it is actually kind of
foreshadowing for how the episode is
gonna turn out overall it's a nice
strong beginning and having him that
certain of himself at the front end also
feeds into where the whole thing goes
and I like it a lot
number seven the stolen Earth this one
almost feels like cheating cuz this is
one of the longer cold opens it goes on
for a while most cold opens to two and a
half minutes this one's more like five
but I we've got the doctor showing up
with Donna like they expect everything
to be a mess Oh Oh seems to be alright
they get back on the TARDIS then the
earth's gone and we get to see all the
characters that we know and love from
all over the planet they're all like oh
boy this is crazy so we get a wonderful
spread in introduction to all the guest
stars who are gonna be in this ending
with Rose oh now we're in trouble
it's just a terrific build and a
culmination really sets the stage for
this being a coming together of
everything that the show has had up to
that point number six this one becomes
relevant because as I said some of these
episodes are not great episodes but 42
this one's just really efficient at
laying out the entire premise of the
episode because cold opens don't usually
do that generally speaking the cold open
just set some mood maybe a tone maybe
set gives you an
instance of a bit of danger but they
usually leave a lot of questions this
doesn't cold-open 442 sets up exactly
what's going on I mean and there's more
to find out because with the monster and
everything else but the sense of
immediate danger we're on a ship it's
gonna crash in the Sun in 42 minutes all
gets established in the cold open it's
quick it's efficient it gives us
everything we need so that once we come
out of the opening credits we can hit
the ground running the episode doesn't
actually run very well it stumbles but
not for lack of a strong open number
five silence in the library this one
actually pulls a little bit of a fast
one cuz technically it does something
that I usually dislike I do not like a
cold open that takes place within the
body of the story we're actually gonna
tell that they just detach and stick on
the front front end it's a basically in
media res teaser and then when the story
starts proper we start before that thing
happened that's why the girl in the
fireplace cold-open is it on here which
isn't a bad cold open but I dislike the
fact that it's it's a segment pulled out
from the middle of the story and this
does technically do that but it gets
away with it for me at least because it
because of the sneaky way it does it
because this opens with the little girl
talking to her doctor doctor moon
closing her mind and imagining her
library that nobody's supposed to be in
but somebody's in it's just this little
girl in an ordinary house imagining a
library and then the doctor and Donna
show up in the library that she's
imagining wait what that is it's just a
wonderfully bizarre way to kick it off
and the reason I'm forgiving of the vibe
because technically what we see here
with the doctor and Donna sort of and
they go up to camera like oh do you mind
if we stop here a bit and we see that
later on when they do that to like
basically a camera droid but the thing
is we are
here from a perspective of what we will
later find out is the computer
completely from how she perceives it and
then later we get it from the perception
of Donna and the doctor as they step in
and see it and it just you just shuts
down
and I think that little twisting of the
perspective on that moment allows this
to get away with it whereas normally I
would have held that against it
maybe I'm also just forgiving because I
love the heck out of this story but I
think it works number four Amy's choice
this is another long one because it is
setting up a pretty complicated premise
because it has to establish the both of
the realities that the characters are
going to be flitting back and forth
between and one of them is not an
obvious one because like the one of them
in the TARDIS in an imminent danger that
just has to set up the danger but this
other one in Upper Leadworth
five years later Amy pregnant that takes
a little more setting up so it takes the
time to do that and to have a nice calm
interaction between the doctor and Amy
and Rory and but then to cut back to the
TARDIS
and be like oh whoa that was weird
wonder what's going on there then back
to upper leg birth again and the dark
saying trust nothing whatever is going
on don't trust anything and he just sort
of takes a step forward this is gonna be
a tricky one I just like the way it
balances it I like the way that it
introduces both the reality I like that
we get the sense of the flitting back
and forth the scent that we get how
disorienting this is for them and we get
that this is going to be this is gonna
be a head I can't say the word that I
want to it's gotta be a bit of a mind
Messing sort of episode and I think this
cold-open sets that up really well after
a nice sort of gentle intro it does the
little twist and we get a sense of
what's coming number three the god
complex when it comes to mysterious
atmospheric moody unsettling and
basically seeing a victim of the monster
of the episode which again that didn't
have a self kind of a typical cold-open
but this one oh man it leaves you with
so many questions and they're all the
best questions what is going on what is
she afraid of what's tracking her why is
she praising it why is she letting it
come to her and all of these questions
will get answered as the episode goes
forward but it sets up the hotel
hallways which are NART dot not dark and
dingy or gloomy it's brightly lit it's
you know it's well-maintained but still
off-putting this seems wrong and that
slightly off senses they're right in the
cold open the whole mood is captured
right there the sense of the fact that
these characters are going to unravel or
the course of the story that's there as
well it does a great great job of
setting up what is a very weird and
oftentimes unsettling episode with a
wonderfully weird and unsettling
cold-open
number 2 The Magician's apprentice this
very nearly came in at number 1 and
about the only reason it didn't is
because some of the visuals and the very
front part of it would like the hand
mines are is a little weird in a way
that doesn't quite work for me it feels
like it's weird just for weird sake but
well the doctor shows up with the TARDIS
offering a hand to this boy and doing
what the doctor does is trying to be
reassuring trying to give the boy
strength bit of a pep talk like come on
tell me the name of the boy who's not
going to die today
the boy says his name is Davros and then
that unbroken no-cut pushing with the
cam
as the doctors face just Falls that oh
whatever you think about this episode
about this series that that opening not
only to this episode but to series nine
Wow
I think that is an astounding episode
and it just lets cap Ali's performance
no dialogue
bird like the real core of this is which
is just his face just lets it say
everything it is so good doesn't take my
number one spot though that is going to
go to an episode that I used to think
much more highly of than I do now I have
a lot of issues with now but I could
have rewatched the cold open all day
long my pick for number one listen the
monologue from the twelfth doctor from
Capaldi's doctor about hiding and what I
love about it is it's the it seems like
he's just basically running through a
thought experiment out loud in the
TARDIS
cuz he's alone he's bored what is that
what else is he gonna do which for me
fits in to the sort of the head Canon
that I have about what the doctor does
when the companion isn't around like in
my head can I intend to picture him just
sitting back and tweaking with the with
the sonic screwdriver just adding new
settings that's why he can do as much as
it can
he's bored and he tinkers with it um but
this fits into that as well he's bored
he's got nothing to do companions not
there okay so uh what can I just sort of
you do to argue PI my brain Oh
unless something that hid so well that
we literally never knew it existed it
was always there for our whole lives and
then for it to end with him going what
would you do what would you do
he turns back to the chalkboard it just
says listen
wonderfully creepy and a great capper to
a monologue that honestly I like in and
of itself beyond the way that it sets up
the episode beyond the way that the
capper at the end of this cold open is
just wonderfully creepy I just let enjoy
this model I mean Capaldi monologues
really well he's really good I he can
command the screen talking to nobody and
he does that here and I am enraptured
and like I said I take issue with a fair
amount of stuff that goes on with this
episode at this point but that cold-open
I think is pretty much flawless so
that's my pick for the 10 best cold
opens of Doctor Who what do you think
about my list what ones do you think I
missed whatever your thoughts are drops
hang on down in the comments let's talk
about it I mentioned the page you're out
again I'll mention it one more time
link down below but if you are unable to
help me in that manner also hitting the
like button
that helps me subscription that helps
you can keep tabs on other stuff I'm
putting out leave a comment as I said
that helps as well and I appreciate all
of it plus there's other links down
there as well links to my other social
media of their creative projects etc etc
etc click on them they'll take you
places or don't I'm not gonna tell you
what to do because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]